I was raised as an only child with two
people who basically hated each other
just enough to stay together so I guess
you could say I've been mediating since
well before I was born years before I
heard the term mutually assured
destruction I was very familiar with it
growing up in that house
Mason Francis Kyle's 45 years old 10
years ago he was deputy chief of mission
here until his wife was killed he's
damaged goods
but he's manageable
maybe one of you can tell me what I'm
doing here three nights ago
American was pulled off the street in
West Beirut next morning we got to
communicate from a group calling itself
the militia of Islamic Liberation but
they have the guy they want to talk they
want you to burger the deal they asked
for you specifically
your friend Cal he's the hostage Cal's
the head of all Mideast operations
he's talks you'll be waiting for bodies
to pile up on the embassy sidewalk what
do you want me to do you're an
experienced negotiator negotiate
Bree what I will track all at I lay for
the return of my brother but I feel the
port-a-john
give me a meeting in Israel Munich
Olympics Madrid flight 305 46 days all
of this feed abou a shadow it is about
you looking for the man who killed your
wife
they can't find your brother you have to
come up with an alternative this is
alternative he's given us six hours to
deliver the brother he's hiding he's
been frozen so deep his own people don't
know where he is
right now there's a hell of a lot
unprotected pieces in this field do you
think they want to say Kallen or do you
think they won't say the information
that's an ugly question
clearly the monsters have taken over
Lebanon something needs to be done and
give Israel the keys to the city
I need to seek out and it's impossible
it's only impossible he's dead
2000 years of revenge and murder
often the Bayreuth
you